[Music]
hello my name is sebastián and I'm a
custom engineer on the
google cloud team today I'm going to talk to you about
google cloud data flow a
batch processing and streaming system
for google cloud in a previous video you already
did a little introduction of what  what
is
data flow but in this video we
will focus a little more on some
concepts and we will see an example of a
real network of the code working let's do
a quick review first
let's see that data flow is a
processing service as we said of data in
batches and streaming and  it is based on the
apache beam open source project which provides a
unified programming model and
houses for different languages data flow is th
way to execute these apach
beam data flows in the googl
cloud in a fully manag
d and optimized way and g
od  what is a data flow or
pipeline in data flow
is a directed cyclic graph
that has data transformations to
one or more c  data connections these
data collections as we have already
mentioned are possibly unlimited and
flow along the edges which means that
they are possibly unlimited that they
can be coming from a
message queue and we are simply
receiving data all the time or they can
be limited as in the  In the case of a
file and in which
these graphs are perfectly exhausted, they can be as
complex as we want with multiple
data inputs and outputs and what is
important to emphasize is that a
data flow is a single unit and is executed and
optimized in this way.  that is, we do not
execute only sections but we
execute the entire data flow the
data flow that they
describe well describes what
you are calculating when
the time of the event is being calculated that is when it
is being calculated based on the
timestamp of the event  to process when
the event is being calculated based
on the time it is processed and also
how we can refine our
results as we get more data
in this way we have the
transformations which are the what the
windows which are the where the
watermarks and triggers which are the when and
the build which is the how
and in this video we  We are going to focus on
the first part, which is what we mean
in the transformations, and well, since
we perform a transformation in data
flow,
we basically have three types of
transformations. The first is to do it
by elements, which would be similar to the
map phase in a Madrid model.  yus the
second that they are aggregation is that it would be
similar to the reviews part and the
third that they are compositions this
means that we can combine
different transformations in a single one
to perform several operations
as well as to be able to reuse the
transformations that we define in other
data flows
let's see the first case the
transformations by elements in data
flow these are defined with the functions  s
for duch whose name comes from
paral·lel du because because we are going to
run this function in parallel
on each of the elements of our
data source and this can scale,
as we said,
millions of operations per second and
can be running on many
machines  At the same time, in a pardon,
we perform a transformation of
each of the elements of a pick
collection that, as we remember, are
our data collections in data
flow and we do it
independently here we have on the right
an example of how we make one of these
stops  and what we are doing is
creating key value pairs from
the first letter so with the
input words we
simply have these
output pairs based on the first letter
that each of our words has we
also
have to know that a pair  de can have
zero one or several output values for each
lement in th
case of the example on the left we se
how we are  os making a tree of
prefixes from each one of the
words so we are having
several go several output values for each
ne of the elements in the example on th
right we have a filter we are filte
ing the words that conta
n the letter s so we have
n  some cases an output value and in
some cases we don't have any output value
what are these unemployed friends well it
turns out that in these transformations
per element we have several
transformations already done to make
our life a little easier so
we have the pair that is  the
general way and we are going to define everything
ourselves but we have some
others that help us to make
transformations that are
commonly used in a simple way for
example we have a filter with which
as we mentioned we have an input and
we put for each element to have an
output or none  we can make a mapping
of elements where for each
input element we have one of sa  lida we can
flatten a map of elements we can
perform a function to each
of the values of our elements we ca
get the keys of our eleme
ts or the values of our elements th
s when we have key value p
irs now let's s
e the second part which are
aggregations or the part of videos in
data flow we work a lot with
key value pairs this allows us to group
data and work with all of them in
each of our functions to make
these groupings we use the
curve function that as we see in this example
once we make  this grouping
we can have each of these
elements unified and this allows us to
work more easily with them how
we can use grup here to calculate
the most common value of each of these
keys
well we can first use our
route bike transformation and then one
of the transformations  also already
included which is the top inter tree,
that is, which is the most  common in an
integrator and this immediately gives us
what this value is
we can also combine data like in
this example where we have each
of our pairs and when we
combine them we combine them through
our key
to the join grouping transformations
also the  sdk includes
several predefined matches for example
what is the largest of a key what is the
smallest and count by key
and do sums and find the maximum
find the mean approximate approximate
quant and read or approximate the single
so we have several
predefined functions that help us  do all
this in a much simpler
way finally we have the compositions
in which we can have a part
within another in which we will see a little later
and well before we mentioned that we can
have multiple outputs so a couple
of can for example have an output
main with all the elements
processed correctly and on the other hand
we have a salt  secondary output with all
the elements that failed to be
processed
now we are going to see an example of a
complete data flow and how to run it in the
cloud attach it for this demo the first
thing we have to do is go to the
google chrome console for that we must go  a
consol dot cloud dot google.com
once there the first part will be to enable
the data flow ipei
we enable it and once it is
enabled we will be able to use it another
thing we have to do is create a
bouquet within google cloud
storage which  we will use it to have our
data output as well as to use it
as a temporary directory of everything we
are processing in this case
we already have one created called let's talk
about cloud data flow demo
then we are going to open the google cloud
shell and the first thing we are going to  to do is to
copy an archetype of may come with one
of these examples
in this case I have already done it
so there is no need to wait for
the first thing we are going to do  is to execute
this data flow locally for this
if we see here we are simply going to
use
the local executor and we are going to see how it
works
as we see the first thing it does is
compile and then it is going to execute it
and that's it we see that it has been executed it took
almost 50 seconds and  it gives us the result right
here we should have it we have
these all these output files are the
output of this data flow now
we are going to see a little what
this data flow does
here we have the code
and we see that here we have the pipeline
so what  first we do is read
from a file then
we count the words then we do a
mapping of the elements and then
we rewrite these files let's
see what this means by counting
the words
this is a pit transform which
we had already talked about and from the  pit
transform we are doing a couple of
things the first is to apply this forgiveness
which is to extract the words so the
first thing we have to do is  we are
reading files with many words and
what we want to do is count how many
words we have of each one so the
first thing is to extract these words
this is a pardo we are simply
extending the feng class and here is
the part where we are processing
so to  each one when we read the
text file it gives us lines and for
each of these lines
and we check that it does not have
blank spaces and we divide all these
elements from a token
and once we have them divided we
simply emit them so this
is the  first part which is to be able to
extract the words after extracting
the words
let's go again now
with quads
the next part we do
after extracting the words then later
we make
a counter element that this is a
function that we also already have
predefined so
we simply count each  one of these elements and we
return that count of elements which
is this work count which simply  e is a
pick collection with value key where
we have each of the words with
how many times this word occurs
so as we can see it is quite
simple but we can see how it is already a
complete example
now we are going to execute it in data flow
for this we have to do it with  another
maiden command in which here
we can see that we have the project which
in this case is let's talk in the cloud
we have the google cloud
storage block that we are going to use as
a temporary directory and where we will have the
data output we are going to execute it
and we are going to see  how it works
if we go to the data floor inside the
console
we can see in this case this is one that
runs
before today and we can see here
this graph that we were talking about before
so we see how we are first
reading the elements then we count
the elements after  we do this mapping
that was the part of seeing the count of
each one of them and well
and mapping each one of those elements to
see
how many  we have each one and finally
we write these elements to a text file
we are going to see what is being executed now,
just the one we have just executed and
we see how each one
of the vertices of our graph is being
executed
and what will happen is that  eventually
in our google cloud
storage folder we will have the output of these
files this was a small
demonstration of how we can
actually use google cloud data flow and with
this we end the second part of
our introduction to data flow
start using google data flow right
now  in cloud dot google.com
diagonal silver flow thank you very much
no